[Music]
for a while story it's getting a lot of
attention the now former CEO of
overstock.com forced to resign this week
he claims that he was involved in the
Russia probe Patrick Byrne laying out
his explosive allegations including that
he was ordered to have an affair with a
Russian spy watch we are the good guys
oh we're not we don't work like the bad
guys but we need to ask you to rekindle
a romantic relationship for the Morea
booty no I was specifically told this
request is coming from Jim call me at
the request of somebody I was given some
fishy orders and I carried them out
thinking I in 2015-2016 thinking I was
conducting law enforcement last summer
watching television and some
congressional hearings I figured out
where those orders came from they gave
him a guy named Peter strong this was
all political espionage conducted
against Hillary Clinton Rubio Cruz and
Trump Wow so Martha this is a wild
interview head-on your show last night a
story and you know why my eyebrows were
flipping out I mean I think these are
bizarre claims but then I noticed he's
not only on your show but several
networks and everybody seems to think
you know what there is something
credible here it's not all to be
dismissed yeah I mean we'll see and I
would not have put him on the show if I
didn't have indications from people who
are close to the investigation that they
his story may be true okay not that it
is true but that there's a suggestion
that he could be telling the truth right
so we asked a lot of questions we gave
an opportunity to just basically tell
his story you know I really let him talk
because I wanted to see where he was
gonna go because he obviously wants to
get some of this off of his chest and I
did speak with him today and I said
what's your reaction to the fact that
James Comey came out and Andrew McCabe
came out and said they didn't know him
that's not the way things work at the
FBI I thought it was interesting that
Andrew McCabe said you know some of the
things that he described are not the way
things work at the FBI so I don't know
which falls into the category of R&R not
but I said you know what's your reaction
he said they're lying through their
well we have a history of that right
yeah like James Cody believes that they
that they know exactly who he is and you
know more to come
all right so just you're a man of great
discretion when it comes to these
matters and I I had the experience I
don't think he meant that listen nice I
do I was listening when I was watching
Martha shines thinking to myself this is
like a spy novel right this goes like he
says Warren Buffett he's Warren Buffett
is his Omaha rabbi right and then Maria
boo Tina is this Russian spy he's
helping the FBI investigate Hillary
Clinton so is this how does it strike
you is this guy telling the truth or is
this like a desperate rant big if true
I've been meeting my deep state fix for
a long time and this has given it to me
I mean you got Comey you got strike I've
got sleeping with Russian spies this is
gonna take me past Labor Day so let's
just say there's no way to prove what he
said at this point but I am open-minded
to hearing what he has to say because it
fits the fact pattern of the rogue
agency the FBI in trapping people
manipulating people for political
reasons and you mentioned it when we
discussed this earlier this goes back to
what the insurance policy because if you
heard him what he said is they were
doing this to multiple politicians
Hillary Rubio Cruz Trump and then as
Trump emerges as the player the focus
goes to him now he's spoken to John
Durham who's running the investigation
of the investigators he has not let me
just clarify that because I don't we
talked about that he offered information
today what happened was he went he spoke
to people at Department of Justice on
April 3rd and April on April 5th and
April 30th
he gave them everything he had his
emails his text messages and all of it
then when the Durham investigation
opened then it got turned over to that
right so we could find out when this
thing's over if he's crazy or if he's
telling the truth or he could be crazy
and telling the truth Wow you know Katie
the the thing is he's the cleanest can t
prove anything like for example are
there pictures of him
Mariya blue tina right yeah you think
there are yeah I saw one okay I've seen
and this can he prove there's one I mean
can he prove that he had this extent and
you know that she was in fact pushing
him to get contacts inside the Clinton
campaign I mean I don't think the issue
is obviously the issue is her pushing
him but the bigger issue that he's
discussing is the FBI he says people at
the top about the rank and file he said
men in black pushing him to have this
relationship with her in order to gain
some kind of political information on
all the candidates that he mentioned so
I think that's the bigger question ray
Betina has been indicted she was
convicted and she's I think in prison
now right so you know she's been dealt
with the issue now that he's bringing
this up is who was behind this and he's
probably feeling out the media landscape
to see you know are people interested do
I go further with this and he probably
should be thinking about getting a
lawyer because he has two concerns that
this is true either that the government
set him up back in the day when the FBI
was run amuck and Peter struck was
running the show and setting up this
Russian collusion narrative or that
maybe you know he engaged in some kind
of bad behavior that could come
illegally galatea on the other end of
things Greg you know that here's what
strikes me he's now got a website called
deep capture calm hmm and he's talking
about something called sift Lord which
is Wall Street and he says these people
are his enemies and they're the ones
that he's left deep you know that yeah
the overstock.com because Seth Lord and
these Wall Street people are out to
break it there's a this is I see three
options here one he is telling the truth
- he's telling the truth but he he's
nuts three he's lying to create some
kind of cloud a conspiracy to deflect
from the SEC investigation but then the
SEC investigations could be part of what
you're saying it's a way to get him so
he can easily planet put that can put
that into the compartment as part of the
bigger conspiracy I think the only way
to know is if other people
who know him say something in the next
couple of days like he has issues or no
this is totally legitimate he's talked
to me about it but if they say look he
has been known to spin tails or all
these people that he's mentioned
especially like Warren Buffett yeah yeah
I would like Warren Buffett should say
hey look he talked to me about this
what he's saying is legit then I would
be more I'd be on firmer ground but
right now I can't tell whether I believe
I believe he believes it I believe he
believes it that's as bad as far as I
can go Wow you gave him some credibility
okay